welcome back everybody we've got Arnold
schweger here and Paul Shaker over with
our band y'all our next guest live on
one of the most famous streets in the
world where children grow smarter
stronger and Kinder you can join them
for season 54 of Sesame Street it
premieres November 9th on Max everybody
please say hello to Elmo and Oscar the
[Applause]
[Music]
gr hey knock it off with all the chering
well yeah don't you know a grouch is in
the house what's up have you Arnold have
you ever met anyone on Sesame Street
have you ever met anybody well they're
good-looking characters I mean like
amazing you too Mr schz so Elmo I I I
heard that you have a question for
Arnold right yes Elma does Elma wanted
to know that you know how can Elma be
strong and healthy just like you cabbage
well
okay very good but the most important
thing is did you eat well okay lot of
vegetables a lot of fruits and did you
exercise every day oh yes okay and you
develop the discipline
okay like this you going to do this see
really well so you do that every day
every day for half an hour to an hour
okay yeah oh you couldn't be tired
already coming out no I was just kidding
that thank you for the advice and
congratulations congratulations Miss
Kelly on your on your new set here it's
wonderful thank you thank you so
much we we love we love it here um so
wait I I love being in the same city as
y'all now I love New York thank you for
the the welcome party this has been
really
cool we're in the same city yeah we're
in the same city now yeah we we are so
excited to have you aren't we Oscar
excited they have is not the word I
would have used but yeah but we're
really we we're happy to welcome you to
this city and you know what to to say
welcome everybody at Sesame Street all
pitched in and got you some things oh
what are direct from Sesame Street oh is
that what's hiding under here is that
what's been hiding okay wait I'm going
to I'm going to reveal it's a little
gift basket from all your friends at
Sesame oh my gosh this is so sweet okay
okay so wait so we're going to go to the
we're this is really cool so I can put
this up just so you know that's not the
sign it's it's but it's a
sign I need to watch more of your
program no this is awesome so I'm going
to put this up I'm going to put this up
here is that okay can I be a part of
Sesame Street with you of course anytime
okay okay thank you okay so wait NE next
we're going to go to what's interesting
little number so oh yeah yeah yeah
that's from me too that's actually for
Mr tight sleeves over here I heard you
had a a new book oh you know what I'm
going to pass this that's
that's actually a bookmark nice nice
Yeah scratch and sniff too scratch and
sniff never lose your
place
yep okay wait this smells terrible thank
you yeah really he's like you're
welcome wait who are these whose are
these are the what are
these you look you look like a Monster
yeah okay you look like a Sesame Street
monster the first time I've been told
yeah no no it's it's it's a good I want
you want to try these on try that on
come on you think you're good looking
now wait a
minute exactly
exactly I'll be
[Applause]
F ready for Halloween I like it wait so
so I should have had those when a did
Terminator I know no trust me your
glasses were cool in that um all right
so wait Elmo I hear that you have advice
for kids with teddy bear so I two kids
what's the advice well well one of those
teddy bears is for you and one of them
is for Mr Arnold oh okay which one would
you like you can pick you know this is
one thing that okay okay one of the
things we learn on Sesame Street that is
if you're feeling nervous or scared you
could give a soft toy that you love a
big hug oh you know you can put it on
your belly and do it's called it's
called belly buddy breathing okay so you
bre and you do it too askar come on
askar okay everybody breathe in through
your nose like this okay and then slowly
breathe out your mouth come on I the do
it I don't have a
nose that is interesting I'll breathe
through your ears
there it's very interesting but but
that's that's just one of the ways that
we we learn how to calm down you know
that's very true I do this with my
children we do breathing exercises it
does really help even for 41 year old
having a rough day um well thank you so
much Elmo thank you Oscar the Grouch
you can see your friends on Sesame
Street anytime on Max season 54 it
premieres November 9th all right so Elmo
Elmo um did you want to say something
with Arnold I heard that you might have
something you want to say with Arnold oh
um yeah oh you know what can we can we
do the can we cut the commercial
together okay okay okay you're done seg
I hear you knows like TV lingo almost
done a lot of shows you know so Elma can
cut to a commercial with Mr Arnold I
like it okay you ready okay okay y'all
can go we'll be back wa minut we'll be
[Applause]
[Music]
back thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home